welcome back to c-span professor Allan
Lichtman he teaches at American
University here in Washington DC his
latest book the case for impeachment
good Sunday morning thank you for being
with us a pleasure Steve from the
opinion section of today's Washington
Post Larry tribe writes this in he's the
professor of Harvard University
Trump must be impeached here's why what
are your thoughts well a long time ago I
wrote my book the case for impeachment
and in it I outlined eight possible
grounds for the impeachment of Donald
Trump which indicated that he was the
first term president most vulnerable to
impeachment in all of history and my
book the case for impeachment it's not
politics it's not punditry I don't quote
a single democratic critic of Donald
Trump I wrote it as a deep historical
analysis of the history of impeachment
the process Trump's history prior to the
presidency and the record of his first
couple of months in office I wrote it so
people can arm themselves with the
knowledge of when Trump might have
crossed the line to begin an impeachment
investigation about the book in just a
moment but you were also one of the few
that would predict Donald Trump was
going to win what was your methodology
and that was actually a formal
mathematical model called the keys to
the White House and I wasn't able to be
right because I ignored the pundits I
didn't look at polls I didn't follow the
day-to-day events of the campaign I kept
my eye on the big picture as gauged by
my prediction system that's been right
since 1984 the keys to the White House
which looks at the vulnerabilities of
the party holding the White House to see
whether it's a change election or not
and I looked at vulnerabilities of the
incumbent Democrats such as their losses
in the midterm elections there
unexpectedly contentious nomination
struggle the fact that they're sitting
president couldn't run again these pesky
third parties running way above their
heads and of course in the Republican
Congress the inability of the Democrats
to follow up the Affordable Care
act with a comparable accomplishment in
the second term and in foreign policy
their inability to follow up the
dispatch of bin laden with something
comparable in the second term so that's
what I looked at and of course the
pundits were trying to follow the polls
and the ups and downs of the campaign
which can be very misleading so when the
returns were coming in election night
you were aware and thinking what you're
not gonna believe where I was al Jazeera
flew me and my wife to Doha and I was in
Doha Qatar the election night analysts
for Al Jazeera and of course you know I
had mixed feelings on the one hand I
kind of enjoyed seeing the pundits twist
themselves into pretzels trying to
explain what had happened which they
just said a few hours ago couldn't
possibly have happened I was glad to see
my system work but I was worried about
the future of the country that's why I
began writing the case for impeachment
and in the book you write the following
quote to impeach or not to impeach that
is the question if the president's
misdeeds are serious not minor or
technical then the answer is yes as
students of history the framers knew
that power corrupts and they established
impeachment as a legal and peaceful
means for escaping tyranny without
having to resort to revolution or
assassination that's right people think
of impeachment as this apocalyptic event
the framers didn't look at it that way
at all they put impeachment into the
Constitution as the ultimate safeguard
of our democracy against a rogue
president they also had checks and
balances of course but they knew a
president could smash through them and
impeachment in their view was the
alternative to the way rulers were
removed in their time by assassination
or revolution and if look at the history
of impeachment
it hasn't been catastrophic for the
country the impeachment of Andrew
Johnson although he wasn't convicted was
good for the country because he
moderated his opposition to the
integration of the newly freed slaves
into a
American life and of course Richard
Nixon resigned in the face of certain
impeachment that was good for the
country because he was a danger to our
political system to our institutions and
finally the impeachment of Bill Clinton
many would say the presidency emerged
stronger than ever maybe too strong
after that I quote in my book the late
great historian author slays in jr. who
said the genius of impeachment is that
it targets the man not the office was
the impeachment of Bill Clinton
justified I was one of those who
believed it was not but there is no
standard for impeachment and the framers
did not put impeachment in the courts
they put it in a political body the
Congress and so impeachment is a
combined moral political and legal
judgment so there's no absolute right or
wrong but the reason I was dubious about
the impeachment of a Clinton even though
his conduct was reprehensible it didn't
cut to the heart of his duties as
president and in my book the case for
impeachment the grounds that I lay out
that could trip up Donald Trump are
definitely related to the presidency and
to our Constitution our liberties and
our national security how significant
was the decision to fire FBI director
James Comey I think it was of the
greatest significance I don't believe
that the firing of James Comey by itself
was obstruction of justice and by the
way Bill Clinton was impeached for
obstruction of justice and the House
Judiciary Committee had an article of
impeachment against Nixon for
obstruction of justice
what is so disturbing about the Comey
firing is the timing right after the
sally aides testimony the issuing of
subpoenas for Michael Flynn and his
associates call me asking for additional
resources the obviously pretextual
justifications and Trump admitting he
was thinking about the Russia
investigation that crash is close to
obstruction of justice but you've got to
add in the whole picture Trump
quite possibly colluding with Devon
Nunez the former head of the House
investigation to derail that
investigation allegations that Trump
asked called me for personal loyalty
which certainly could strengthen a case
for obstruction of justice and then the
thinly veiled threat he gave to call me
about not talking about their
interactions put all of that together
and I think you have a prima facie case
to at least begin not an impeachment but
an impeachment investigation on
obstruction of justice along with
possible collusion with Russia along
with possibly violating the Constitution
by taking things of value from foreign
countries and in your book you of course
quote the US Constitution let's just
give you a quick primer on the issue of
impeachment the president vice-president
and all civil officers of the United
States shall be removed from office on
impeachment for and conviction of
treason bribery or other high crimes and
misdemeanors that's often than the issue
of how do you define high crimes and
misdemeanors and also the process of
course the House of Representatives
shall have the sole power of impeachment
to make the formal charges against those
individuals the Senate will have sole
power to try all impeachments but no
person shall be convicted without the
concurrence of two-thirds of the members
present right so impeachment is just the
first step it's like in an indictment
and it just requires a majority vote of
the house and by the way there's no
appeal you can't go to the courts and
appeal and impeachment and then of
course there's a much higher hurdle for
removal as you point out a president is
tried in the Senate with the trial
presided over by the Chief Justice of
the US Supreme Court and it does take a
two-thirds vote two presidents have been
impeached of course Andrew Johnson and
Bill Clinton neither one was convicted
by the Senate but if you are convicted
by the Senate by the way you are subject
to criminal penalties for anything
you've done while President you lose
your immunity let's go to your phone
calls with Professor Allan Lichtman his
latest book the case for impeachment and
we'll go
Debra in Pennsylvania independent line
good morning good morning to you and
thank you so much for c-span Thank You
Allan Lichtman I've been following you
appreciated Debra what a pardon I
appreciate it yeah I really have now my
question pertains to I don't know what
category it's under but the fact that he
has had 70 pending lawsuits prior to the
election 34 added on since the fact that
the that the Washington Post recently
did some fact-checking and on the first
hundred days he had 492 false or
misleading claims and people can look
this up you know as they did a category
job foreign policy health care
environment exposure there's any of this
impact you know this decision-making
process got it thank you
got it great question Debra and I do
have a chapter in the case for
impeachment on presidential lies and of
course I go through his whole history of
lying as well prior to the presidency he
of course got into politics by
perpetrating the biggest most protracted
lie in the history of American politics
the lie that the first african-american
president was illegitimate because he
was born outside the United States but
how can this lead to impeachment very
simply the impeachment of Bill Clinton
proceeded from a civil suit the Paula
Jones sexual harassment suit where he
was alleged to have lied under oath
which led to a grand jury investigation
the same thing can happen to Donald
Trump if the courts decide that won a
war of civil lawsuits could go forward
then Donald Trump may well have to
testify under oath and if he reverts to
his typical pattern of lying and if he
lies under oath he could be charged with
the same article of impeachment that the
house charged against Bill Clinton and
his perjury steve has this tweet Trump
will never be impeached puts in
parentheses you're fired he will make
sure Pence is ready to pardon and then
resign I think that's possible Richard
Nixon of course resigned in the face of
certain impeachment and it's not as if
if Donald Trump resigns he'd go off to
live in some hobble somewhere out in the
middle of nowhere
he'd go back to his luxurious
millionaire lifestyle and as I point out
in the case for impeachment Donald
Trump's history has been of walking away
from difficult situations and leaving
others holding the bag by declaring
bankruptcy or simply abandoning a failed
business deal or settling out a lawsuit
for peanuts given his riches so I don't
think that's an impossible scenario you
mentioned Richard Nixon that famous
photograph of him on marine one August
9th 1974 as he headed back to San
Clemente California and it was less than
a year earlier when he fired special
prosecutor Archibald Cox Elliot
Richardson who was the Attorney General
stepped down immediately william rekkles
house who was the Deputy Attorney
General also stepped down the so-called
Saturday night massacre that led to the
appointment of Leon Jaworski that's
correct and you know many have compared
the Saturday night massacre to Donald
Trump's so-called Tuesday night massacre
when he fired the FBI director now in
both cases they had the legal right to
fire them by the way it wasn't that they
were violating the law it's rather the
issue of whether or not they were
obstructing justice and by the way it
was the firing of Archibald Cox not the
release of the White House tapes many
months later that was the tipping point
for Richard Nixon it was that firing
that turned the public against him and
it was that firing that started an
impeachment investigation in the house
that some eight or nine months later led
to the Judiciary Committee of voting
favorably for articles of impeachment
and by the way about a little more than
a third of Republicans on the Judiciary
committee voted for at least one article
of impeachment and remains to be seen
whether the firing of James Comey will
have the same trigger effect and start
an impeachment investigation of Donald
Trump and then impeachment investigation
it's what is what's needed not a special
prosecutor Trump gets to appoint a
special prosecutor he could fire the
special prosecutor the rate the way
Richard Nixon did and special
prosecutors take years and years to do
their work Allan Lichtman who has been a
professor at American University since
1973 a graduate of Brandeis University
earned his doctorate from Harvard
University he is the author of keys to
the White House since 1984 he has
successfully predicted every winner of
every election which is quite an
accomplishment it's it's a long run yeah
I keep waiting for it to end but it's
it's it's because I don't look at the
throne on the waves you know the
day-to-day episodes of campaigns that
really don't matter I keep my eye on the
big picture of things like third parties
midterm elections nomination fights the
economy foreign policy social unrest and
scandal and I would advise all your view
is to do the same keep your eye on the
big picture of elections and don't
listen to what happens day to day I
understand the media has to cover
elections day to day but that doesn't
mean that's what turns elections David
has this tweet I bet Trump is crafting a
tweet right now bashing mr. Lichtman I
look forward to it it's been a Brad
Springfield Virginia good morning
Republican line good morning Steve and
professor Lichtman good to see you again
I actually am a graduate of American
University and I took your history of
presidential elections class several
years ago Wow nice
you met do you remember the grades you
got Brad I don't want to say as of right
now you're on the record so that I don't
remember so you're safe my question is
about the keys though for just one quick
SEC sure and that was I remember in
class you talked about that in 2000 your
keys were right because of the popular
vote right how does that square way with
today with
past election when President Trump
actually lost the popular vote but won
the electoral college
great question and you know when I first
devised the keys over 30 years ago in
1981 the popular vote drove the
electoral college vote you had to go all
the way back to 1888 to find a
divergence and that was a very fluky
election but there has been a profound
change in our politics which no one has
talked about and I'm glad you brought it
up and it's the one tweak in the keys
and that is in any closed election which
is the only elections that are tough to
call the popular vote doesn't matter
anymore the only thing that matters of
the electoral college for the simple
reason that Democrats will always win
now the popular vote in a very close
election because they get 6 million
extra popular votes in New York and
California alone and what does that
count for in the electoral college 0
that's why this time I didn't qualify my
prediction as too popular or electoral
college I simply said Trump would be the
next president but Brad you paid
attention in my class and years later
I'm very proud of you Brad thank you for
the question and the call will go to
Bryan and Michigan independent line or
talking with Allan Lichtman professor at
American University wait ok thanks so I
guess I'll put you down for a maybe as
far as Trump's presidency I think the
real problem arise arose out of 9/11
with the Homeland Security President
Bush and the Patriot Act which was
basically rolled out and shoved down our
throat now that coincided with the
unparalleled the way we capture data now
so basically our government paid for by
us and you and everyone else is
basically spying on everyone and our
government is not equipped for that well
I'm not sure that's quite up the line of
the case for impeachment I don't
disagree with you I've kind of abandoned
the idea of personal privacy I
I've gotten to the point where I figured
I might as well assume everything I say
and do is going to be broadcast down the
middle of Pennsylvania Avenue at high
noon nothing anyone would care that much
about it but but I think you're right we
are living in a post privacy age erica
san diego good morning democrats line
yeah good morning I'm so glad this man
is on here
to tell the truth I can't stand to even
watch this man that lived in the White
House now and on television I changed my
channel and look away I can send you the
voice I mean and he is far as I'm
concerned no matter what he never would
be one we could talk about the popular
vote it should be though the popular
vote I know explaining all that but I
don't most people I want here in 10 D
with my neighbors they all voted for
Hillary and we just can't stand what's
going on there and in the White House
and this man still has all his product
meat in China you Erica you raise an
important point another ground for
impeachment that I point out in my book
the case for impeachment a whole chapter
on it is conflicts of interest I also
have a chapter in the case from
Pietschmann called the way out in which
I give Trump some advice on how we can
avoid impeachment and Vice number one is
divest all your business interests sure
you take a financial hit but you're a
billionaire still be a billionaire and
besides no one forced you to run for
president
he hasn't divested and the problem is
that he still profits from all his
business ventures and he still knows
what's going on even if it's nominally
run by his children and there is
something in the Constitution called the
emoluments clause which simply put means
if your present you can't take anything
about you whether there's a quid pro quo
or not from a foreign nation their
entities or their agents and Trump is
already crashing into the emoluments
clause for example as president he
received final approval 438 all
potentially lucrative trade marks from
China and of course the domestic
conflicts of interest are rampant and we
don't even know the full extent of his
flicks of interest because unlike all
other recent presidents he refuses to
release his tax returns let me go back
to this editorial in the New York Times
called oval office etiquette a GOP guide
and you mentioned something that the New
York Times is pointing it's also
available on the website at nytimes.com
and it's the issue of reviewing
discussing highly sensitive intelligence
in a restaurant and allowing the army
officer carrying the nuclear football to
be photographed and identified by name
hiring relatives four key White House
posts and then letting them meet with
foreign officials and engage in business
at the same time promote family
businesses on federal government
websites tweet tweet tweet
collude with members of Congress to try
to shut down investigations of you and
your associates threatened military
conflict with other nations in the
middle of news interviews compare US
intelligence community to Nazis repeat
untruths and then lie and concludes with
this if you are a Republican legislator
stick this list on the fridge and give
it a quick read the next time you get
upset at a president absolutely and not
all of those things are in P chable but
they set the context for impeachment
speech might remember is in a political
body and I've been asked a lot how is it
a Republican Congress could impeach a
Republican president and one of the
Lichtman rules of politics is if you're
an incumbent your first requisite is
survival and if Republicans in Congress
come to believe that Trump is a
liability to their survival they could
well decide to join with Democrats to
impeach them and they may well prefer to
have Mike Pence the predictable down the
line conservative Republican as
president then the unpredictable loose
cannon Donald Trump and by the way if
Democrats stand firm it would only take
some two dozen Republicans that's just
ten percent of Republicans in the House
and about that many sit in districts one
by guess ooh Hillary Clinton let's go to
Jeff in Crofton Nebraska Republican line
good morning yeah I got to tell you the
standards that you're setting a bill
clinton the lied to a grand jury
i'm quite sure
if he got away with it we can certainly
afford to give Trump the same courtesy
and I'm going to tell you even if
Hillary would have won I held a top
secret at CIA clearance because I did
all the communications onboard the White
House helicopters and I'm sure that if I
had a server sitting at my house running
everything through that that I would
have been an 11 worth the rest of my
life Jeff will get a response thank you
we're not gonna relitigate Hillary
Clinton's emails my book the case for
impeachment is about the current
president Hillary Clinton had been
elected we can go through that uh Bill
Clinton did not you know he would lying
to a grand jury he was impeached for
lying to a grand jury he wasn't
convicted but he was charged and my
point was if Trump does the same thing
he too could be charged and then you'd
have to of course have a trial in the
Senate and the particular facts of what
he did would then be hashed out but Bill
Clinton certainly didn't get away with
it and since you are professor Allan
Lichtman why was President Johnson
impeached President Johnson was
impeached technically because he
violated something called the tenure of
office Act which limited his ability to
fire and replace cabinet members very
technical and later the Supreme Court at
least in dicta said this was an
unconstitutional intrusion on
presidential powers but he was really
impeached because he was impeding the
reconstruction process particularly the
integration of newly freed slaves into
American life he wasn't convicted he
fell one vote short of conviction but he
was a chastised president and he
moderated his opposition and the
impeachment was good for the country who
led that impeachment that that was led
of course by the Republicans in Congress
and what you had house managers going
like Ben Butler going into the Senate to
make the case for impeachment and by the
way if Johnson had been removed
there was no vice-president so that at
that time under the Secession rules and
by the way except for the vice-president
the rules are not in the Constitution
they set by Congress a very unpopular
President Pro Tem of the Senate Ben Wade
would have been president let's go to
Charles in Schoolcraft Michigan
independent line professor Allan
Lichtman the book the case for
impeachment good morning Charles thank
you
just real quick congressman Chaffetz
resigning noonas recusing himself
sessions recused himself especially the
vice president vice president tense when
he contradicted the president on the
firing and it was put in the press that
he was actually present when the
president decided to fire call me but
the other thing is tense taking over for
Christie in the transition team and
should have known more about general
Flynn in his dealings with the Russians
and I wonder what I'm trying to say is
how much would like vice-president
pension be caught up in any kind of
impeachment thank you Charles thank you
for the question that's a terrific
question
I've pondered that myself you know Pence
has gotten kind of a free ride well he
lied to the public about Michael Flynn
because Michael Flynn lied to him he
lied to the public about the real reason
why Comey was fired because he was lied
to well maybe so but there's another
explanation for all of this that maybe
pence himself is involved in some of
these allegations about collusion with
the Russians and maybe was involved in
the Comey
firing and you know if you look at
Pence's performance during the debates
as well the one vice presidential debate
he wasn't very truthful he kept denying
that Trump said things that Trump had
actually
said I don't know is here but I don't
think we ought to automatically give
pence a free pass I think we need to
look into pence as well and by the way a
vice-president no less than a president
is impeachable and this is from Jody
will conclude with this tweet thank your
guests for being Joe Friday today just
the facts and not floating away on
alternative facts you know there are no
saying such things as alternative facts
I'm a professor I've spent my life
teaching students how to gather evidence
to scrutinize evidence to analyze
evidence and things like alternative
facts or post post truth go against
everything I've stood for for more than
40 years and I've written about in the
case for impeachment this is the book
the case for impeachment by American
University professor Allan Lichtman
thank you very much for stopping by
my pleasure he's come back again and
happy birthday thank you